[Music]
november 22nd 1987 was a pretty normal
evening for television viewers in
chicago
that night like every night dan roan was
covering sports on wgn tv channel 9.
then suddenly the signal was disrupted
and screens across the city
cut to black engineers at wgn tv thought
their transmitters were failing
they weren't a few seconds later this
happened
what this wgn's broadcast signal had
been hijacked in what is now known as
the max headroom incident
wgn tv was able to act quickly and get
their signal back
but two hours later it would happen
again to another tv station
and there was nothing they could do to
stop it so what happens next remains one
of the most bizarre
unsolved crimes in television history
let's find out why
[Music]
because you are going to see it as well
yes it
yes it yes namely the max syndrome
stream
story at 9 14 p.m dan roan disappeared
from wgn tv
in fact everything disappeared then 15
seconds later
something crazy happened wearing a
rubber mask and sunglasses
the hacker looked like artificial
intelligence television character max
headroom
the new max didn't say anything but that
doesn't make him any less frightening
after about 30 seconds of horror
technicians at wgn were able to switch
their uplink frequency and bring dan
rohn back on the air
and he did a nice job of keeping his
composure but he
clearly was unsettled well if you're
wondering what's happened so am i
actually the computer that we have
running our news from time to time
took off and went wild the engineers
figured that this was an inside job
conducted by an employee so they started
tearing apart the studio
looking for the perpetrator they didn't
find anyone turns out the pirate
broadcast was pre-recorded
and the signal was hacked by a third
party but somehow this third party was
able to intercept the wgn uplink and
push their own signal through wgn tv's
antenna
on top of the john hancock building but
the tv pirates weren't finished yet
two hours later on pbs channel 11 in the
middle of a doctor who episode
max was back and this time he had lots
to say
that is the only way to learn i'll get
you a hot drink
some dry clothing these are freaking
nerves
i think that they're just worse
[Music]
oh jesus
[Applause]
[Music]
me
is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
oh i just made a giant bastard case for
all
the greatest world newspaper nerds
my brother wearing the other one
[Music]
as far as i can tell a massive electric
shock he died instantly
no really what the actual so for this
second performance there were no
engineers on duty they had gone home for
the day so the transmission played all
the way through
and when it was over the signal was
returned to channel 11.
and barely an hour later the fcc and the
fbi began an investigation that would
turn the
entire television industry upside down
the hunt for max headroom was on
oh look at that you cannot beat that for
a first prize
well you can't but i can now most tv
viewers in 1987
the face of max headroom was instantly
recognizable he was called the world's
first computer generated tv host
max headroom originally appeared in the
cyberpunk tv movie
max headroom 20 minutes into the future
which was broadcast in 1985.
in fact he had a show on the air at the
time it ran on channel 4 in the uk
and on abc in the us from 1987 to 1988
the show was eventually cancelled when
it was beaten in the ratings by miami
vice
[Music]
oh it's tough to compete with crackit
and tubs it is
a late night talk show on cinemax and a
few tv specials
had made max headroom a cult sensation
and eventually he would become an 80s
icon
the max headroom story takes place in a
dystopian future
and in this future television networks
rule the world even the government
functions as a puppet of the network
executives whose job is mainly to pass
laws to keep people watching like
removing off switches from tvs
a tv technology had advanced to the
point that viewers physical movements
and thoughts
could be monitored through their
television sets i bet
facebook and google love this future
the only real check on the power of the
networks is edison carter
an investigative journalist who exposes
their unethical practices
now the networks don't like this but
carter gets big ratings so they have to
keep him around
so one day he's injured in a motorcycle
accident and the last thing he sees
before he blacks out
is a sign that says max headroom 2.3
meters
oh so desperate to maintain ratings with
its star reporter
the network hires a hacker to upload
carter's mind into an ai
and max headroom was born and despite
what most people think
max was not really computerized he was
played by matt frewer who wore makeup
and prosthetics and sat in front of a
blue screen
max headroom was designed to be a parody
of real-life tv newscasters where the
line between news and entertainment
was getting more and more blurry that
line is gone now
it definitely is max headroom was
conceived as a cyberpunk on mainstream
tv a voice to rail against the
establishment and corporate
conglomerates
and the world he described in 1987
turned out to be
pretty close to what we're living now
have you any idea how 666 successful
censorship is on tv don't know the
answer
successful isn't it
okay let's break down the video and how
the hacker managed to pull this off in
the first place
max starts with he's a freaking nerd
the people have speculated that the
beginning of the video was cut off so
we're not really sure what he means
but we do know how he created this voice
by running the audio feed through an
analog
ring modulator you can create this
effect and it might not have been an
accident that max hijacked a doctor who
episode doctor who fans are very
familiar with the evil daleks
famous for saying
[Music]
and to create the daleks voice the audio
was run through a ring modulator now
today this is completely done with
software but in 1987
this would have been done with an analog
effects pedal that could have been
purchased from any music shop
so maybe max was a doctor who fan
max is referring to the chicago bulls
announcer who is then wgn radio's top
sportscaster
the background behind him was a cheap
piece of corrugated metal that you can
get at any hardware store
it was mounted on some kind of spindle
that was rotated by someone off camera
now holding what looks to be a marital
aid
max yells the new coke slogan catch the
wave
max headroom was the spokesperson for a
huge coca-cola campaign
and made this catchphrase instantly
famous more people are as we
go colleges say catching the way
catch it if you can can catch the wave
coke
um excuse me yeah so the guy who's
against huge corporations
had a brand deal with a huge corporation
ah i see the hypocrisy in that anyway
maxton hums the theme to the 1960s
cartoon clutch cargo and says i still
see the x
[Music]
now this is a direct reference to clutch
cargo's final episode
i want to take a closer look at that
thing break out the spacesuits better
right clutch you know i don't like the
human mouth on those characters
oh you don't like that huh not one bit
it creeps me out
i know how you feel by the way that type
of animation is called syncrobox
and it was used in the 50s and 60s as a
way to keep animation costs down it was
also used frequently on conan in the 90s
and early 2000s in case it looks
familiar
just want to wish you and all your loved
ones a very happy
you're fired okay well donald trump
everybody yeah i don't care for that
next max says i just made a giant
masterpiece for all the greatest world
newspaper nerds
now this is another dig at chicago's
television establishment
the call sign of the station wgn was an
abbreviation for world's greatest
newspaper a slogan taken from the
chicago tribune
and the tribune owned the tv station now
let's see how he did it
this one for the video pirates who
managed to scramble chicago airwaves the
pirates interrupted wgn
and wttw programming with a show of
their own
our mike kersh has more someone wants to
get into your house
they can find a way to do that and i
guess likewise if someone wants to
interfere with your signal they can find
a way to do that
while some viewers were entertained by
this prank the stations and the
government
were not amused officials from the fcc
pledged to track down the perpetrators
and bring them to justice
agents from the fbi's chicago field
office also joined the investigation
like to inform anybody involved in this
kind of thing that
there's a maximum penalty of a hundred
thousand dollars
uh one year in jail or both there was a
growing fear among law enforcement
the military and communications experts
that our signals were vulnerable
imagine the chaos you can cause if you
tried something like this with
military transmissions at the time of
the max headroom hack
broadcast signal intrusions were
considered rare limited to small
low power stations and special knowledge
was required and equipment that
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars or
more were needed a city like chicago
didn't think they were vulnerable
to hijack a television or radio station
signal you don't even have to be in the
studio
how many stations work is the signal is
sent on low power from the studio to a
big antenna
this is called the studio transmitter
link or stl
then the big antenna takes the stl
amplifies it and broadcasts it
max knew this and was able to position a
piece of equipment in between the studio
and the tower then all he had to do was
transmit to the tower on the correct
frequency and push out a signal that had
more power than the studios
apparently somebody with some microwave
equipment was able to
interfere with our signal going to the
hancock transmitter well this is not
just anybody off the street he has to
have an electronic expertise of some
level right
yes he does it takes very sophisticated
equipment to uh to do this
at a significant power level now
obviously this takes a lot of knowledge
about telecommunications
but if you have good line of sight to
the tower it could be done with
relatively cheap equipment
now before you get the idea that you
want to try this remember a
it's illegal and b signals are now
encrypted so
that system really wouldn't work now max
probably didn't come up with this idea
himself
just one year earlier hbo endured an
embarrassing hack
this intrusion was perpetrated by the
now infamous captain midnight
there is nothing wrong with your
television set
do not attempt to adjust the picture we
are controlling transmission april 27
1986 that night hbo broadcast the falcon
and the snowman
falcon in a winter soldier snowman yeah
i don't think you're right about that
i am anyway at around 32 minutes past
midnight the screen flickered into color
bars with a message
superimposed on top
i love this guy lasting about four and a
half minutes
the message from captain midnight was
america's first known
broadcast signal intrusion hbo execs
didn't publicly discuss the incident
which was a protest of the recently
announced price hike within a few days
fcc investigators had found the hacker
captain midnight was a satellite
technician named john mcdougall
who worked for a satellite uplink
company in ocala florida at the end of
his shift
mcdougall flipped a dish in the
direction of hbo satellite and broadcast
his message
overpowering the network signal he
explained to investigators that he was
frustrated that the network's rising
fees
which hurt his other business selling
satellite tv equipment
after pleading guilty to charges of
transmitting without a license
a violation of federal law mcdougall
paid a five thousand dollar fine
now to this day mcdougall doesn't regret
the incident
he said hbo was deliberately gouging
satellite customers in order to get them
to switch to cable now it turns out
he was 100 right that's exactly what hbo
was doing and it worked
just because something's not legal
doesn't mean it's not right
i couldn't agree more it generated
hundreds of calls really kind of
expressing
uh sympathy over the fact that
our signal would be interfered with us
in this way and that it would
inconvenience so many thousands of our
viewers
the incidents are now under
investigation by the fcc
and the fbi but the odds i'd say if a
guy continues to
involve himself either sporadically or
continuously it's very great that we
will
determine who it is the investigation
into the max headroom incident went on
for a while but eventually the trail
went cold
the fcc and fbi weren't prepared for
this type of investigation and the
agencies
weren't cooperating with each other ever
since 1987
people have speculated about who max was
from local dial-up bbs's
to reddit there are tons of theories
eventually each theory is debunked
and to this day nobody has come forward
now most people believe that it was an
employee
with an axe to grind against wgn but
nobody really knows for sure
there was no message there was no motive
and decades later no perpetrator
it seems like it was done purely for the
curiosity
and the glory of simply doing it that's
good enough for me
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files
if you had fun or learned anything today
comment like subscribe
share really helps out the channel the
algorithm is a succubus
who wants to seduce us and harvest our
essence
but with your help we can defeat her
when you say essence do you mean never
mind that
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you